رئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب وجد اخيرا
صوتا ينصفه وسط قائمه القضايا التي تلاحقه
الموضوع يتعلق بقضيه التدخل الروسي في
حمله ترامب الانتخابيه لعام 2016 الرئيس
الجمهوري السابق تحصل على صدقي براءته من
التهم الموجهه اليه فالمدعي العام المكلف
بالتحقيق في قضيه جوندورهم اكد ان مكتبه
تحقيقات الفيدرالي فتح تحقيقه بناء على
معلومات غير مؤكده كما سهم درهم في
تقريرهم نهائي المحققين بالتحيز بل وتجاهل
غياب اي تبرير منطقي للادله التي تقود
الفرضيه حول مؤامره مزعومه بين ترامب
وموسكو
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات